Donavan the sinks surround the British
trader accused of helping to cause the
flash crash in 2010 was granted bail of
5 million pounds while he fights
extradition to the US conditions of the
bed include that he sleeps at his
parents home in Hounslow a West London
suburb Brian Chilcote is there for a
second day Ryan good morning what else
do we know
good morning mark well we also know that
other conditions include he has to be at
his home between the hours of 11:00 p.m.
and 4:00 a.m. that's just to ensure that
of course he is sleeping at the family
home here in this West London suburb
additionally he has to report three
times a week to the police station here
in Hounslow he has forfeited his
passport and of course as you said he
has to pony up that five million pound
bail we spoke with his lawyer yesterday
and says he does have the five million
pounds in addition to another hundred
thousand pounds roughly
and some betting accounts he has though
it's not entirely clear a mark that he
has actually posted bail just yet a lot
of reporters already this morning
turning up again here in West London
waiting for mr. sorrow to appear in
front of the mark and what more will be
learning about his trading practices
well you know we are learning that he's
been trading for a very long time at his
home but also at trading outfits
including one outside of London in the
city of Woking where he worked when he
was in his 20s but I mean he is a day
trader with significant amount of
experience now what has happened over
the last 24 hours is people have begun
to ask the question of who's really to
blame here criminal charges aside that
the US has opened against him is it the
regulators or is it mr. sorrow himself
that's a conversation happening in the
marketplace a lot of people say mr.
sorrow was just a lone trader a day
trader and you know is it really fair to
blame him for causing an entire market
collapse was he really capable of that
what about the regulator's what about
the individuals running the markets that
mr. Sorrell was operating on like the
futures market run by the CME stateside
in Chicago and there are a couple of
questions for example on the penalty
side there was another individual that
was found in gated found engaging in
this so-called spoofing and layering
where you placed a trade without the
intention of ever executing it to push
the market in one direction or another
doing it was effectively doing something
very similar to what mr. Rowe mr. sorrow
has been accused of between 2010 and
2011 he was caught and his fine was
$150,000 and he was banned for trading
for one month there are a lot of people
now and he could read about this in a
very good editorial in The Financial
Times saying you know is that enough of
a sanction and then there are questions
about whether this could have been
caught earlier we do know some somewhat
disturbing facts for example from the
affidavit the US prosecutors alleged
that mr. Sorrell was actually contacted
by CME
in March of 2010 in other words two
months before the flash crash and he was
told that he must ensure that his trades
are indeed
bonafide trades and not sort of these
ghost trades where the trade actually
never
happens it's just meant to move the
price of an instrument and he was even
contacted on May the 6th 2010 the day of
the flash crash and yet he continued on
trading and according to the affidavit
even had the gall if you will - later
that month in May of 2010 tell his
broker you know I called those guys at
CNE and I told them to kiss my
you-know-what so there's a lot of
questions about you know what the
responsibility is say it's eme and at
these markets in general but also the
federal government the United States the
regulator's what are they doing to make
sure that the markets are safe not
vulnerable to these kinds of things and
being accurately or well regulated mark
Ron thank you we'll speak to you again
later
right Chilcote in Hounslow today